hi hearties all over the world welcome
back for yet
another live virtual event celebrating
season eight
of when calls the hearts i'm deidre
behar from entertainment tonight
and i as always feel so lucky to be
joined by some of the most talented
people on television
they really need no introduction but
please help me welcome erin krakow
pascal hutton and kevin smith
hi hello
obviously i just got to address the
obvious we're still here at home but
we're doing things virtually we're
celebrating when calls the heart
before we get started i just want to
touch base aaron how are you doing are
you at home what's been going on
i'm good i'm at home i'm in california
the weather's beautiful that's been a
nice perk but yeah i have really nothing
to complain about it's been so nice to
get to watch
one calls the heart with all the
hardee's every week and feel like we're
all
at least virtually together in that way
but yeah i'm doing fine
thanks of course yes queen of the gifts
we love tweeting along with you on
sunday nights
uh pascal you're right there with aaron
firing off some hilarious tweets every
sunday
what has life been like for you
yeah i mean well kevin and i just got
back it feels like still fairly recently
from hawaii
which was amazing which we'll talk about
later
but uh yeah so it just feels uh life is
good
life is good it's beautiful here in
vancouver and i'm with my family
and uh yeah it's good
good good good and uh kevin do you have
anything to report in terms of new
loaves of bread and new cream
i've got nothing to report as far as
that goes but i want to be real
things are not going so well my wife was
not happy that i went to hawaii without
her
so when i got home all the work of the
household just
fell onto my shoulders and she
disappeared
i don't know where she is
you know who worked like a dog at home
to make up for having gone to hawaii and
have a lot of fun with this one it's
through the movie so i'm paying for it
big time right now
life's about balance kevin sometimes
you're in paradise and sometimes you got
to do the home renovations
it's so true right okay well i want to
get right into it uh we've got
one more episode left in season eight of
when calls the heart
um kevin and pascal i want to start with
you know lee and rosemary and their
trajectory throughout this season
it's been so beautiful to watch their
journey as a couple and
they're really diving into their
passions and finding out what they want
to do
with their lives and what brings them
purpose so in this final episode that
we're gonna see on sunday
um pascal let's start with you what can
you tease about what is in this
this final chapter of season eight for
rosemary
i think what we i i think what we see
with rosemary in this final episode
is kind of a renewed excitement and
renewed passion
and a uh focus
i think she's found a focus and she's
really excited about that
and that's gonna kind of propel into
hopefully
season nine and um yeah so that's
that's where we're at with rosemary and
i think the two of them as a couple have
kind of
found a found a focus i think there was
some time there seasons where they were
trying to wrap their head around the
the the loss of a dream that they
thought was going to unfold very
easily for them and hasn't uh
which is having a child and i think when
that doesn't
unfold easily i think a couple kind of
has to
redefine and what their purpose in life
is going to be because when they've
assumed that it's going to be one other
thing
they have to kind of rethink that and
that's where we've been for a few
seasons and i think you see the two of
them kind of
finally get a little spark of something
that's exciting them
oh my gosh i so many things just came to
mind okay first of all
when you say rosemary is going to have
like a renewed
i don't know sense of joy or passion
ignite i mean my mind immediately goes
to theater
um are we gonna maybe see her make a
grunge return to the stage or could it
be possibly something totally different
you know i can't tell you that
[Music]
[Laughter]
is there anything to tune in what i will
say though and i think what we've come
to
appreciate about rosemary is she is
never shy to
to uh redefine herself
and try something new on
and jump into the adventure of that and
so
um that's all i'm gonna give you
wow okay well i cannot wait to see what
adventure lies ahead for queen rosemary
um kevin similarly for lee you know he's
been having a lot of conversations with
joseph about
fulfillment um are we gonna see you know
a beautiful you know bow
tied up on the end of that by the time
we get to the finale
i certainly think that we're going to
get a lot closer to a bow maybe the
finger on the ribbon maybe not a totally
tied off bowl but at least a finger on a
ribbon
okay and as an actor what's great about
um
about this sort of scenario is often you
come into a show
the character i mean i've always tried
to have a backstory for them and as
they've written in my backstory turns to
dust because none of it applies
but we get to see a renewed interest of
where he comes from
and where he's going so it's like when
you take somebody's passion and he
doesn't even really know
what it is he's searching for it he's
just not fulfilled in the way that maybe
like pascal said
if the uh the family thing didn't go as
planned so they have to reevaluate a
little bit and i think
watching joseph um you know and such a
self-effacing guy and accepts his
destiny and i think
lee is inspired by that and it gets him
thinking
and searching and and i i love that as
an actor because now i get to have it
from its
from its birth so this whole inception i
get to play
right from the very beginning instead of
having to try and make up a backstory
that either catches up or doesn't
so i was super excited about it we've
been talking about this
thing for a season or two going back and
you know where are the characters going
and i think that it's really exciting
to kind of have a rebirth of where we
are and where we're going
wow no haven't intended on the rebirth
well you know similar similar to how i
think it's so beautiful that lee and
rosemary really
opened up about something that affects
so many couples i think it's also so
wonderful what we've seen this season
which is
you can discover new passions at any
point in your life and it could be
anything under the sun whatever fuels
you and makes you excited
go for it and i really love that we've
seen that with the two of them i'm
excited to see what's next
erin i i gotta pivot to you because look
i know you a little bit in real life and
what i know is you are a tried and true
girls girl and it pains me
every time i have to see a scene where
rosemary and and elizabeth are sort of
at odds
so i'm hoping that you can sort of put
us at ease maybe a little bit and let us
know
are they gonna hug and make up
i mean look what i'll say about that is
this is hope valley and we strive for
happy endings and happy relationships
and friendships and
and i know for myself and for pascal as
well this
getting to tell the story of this female
friendship in such a healthy
way has been very important to both of
us they're they are
always supportive of each other they
always love each other and i think that
love and support is really
and communication and honesty those are
all things that make up the backbone of
their friendship
and that isn't something that would be
just
thrown away in any kind of cavalier way
so
um i would encourage the hardys to be
hopeful and patient
and i think that um elizabeth and
rosemary
will find their way back to each other
people are not happy with with uh where
we were at in the wedding episode
i know the elizabeth apology
in the dress shop not satisfying for
anybody i got so many comments like
not good enough well i agree
i agree i don't think it was good enough
i think that there's really
there's more work that needs to be done
in order for these two women to
reunite as the the best friends that
they are
and we're just we're not quite there yet
but they had to put their problems aside
for florence and ned and i think they
did all right
they managed oh 100 kept it very very
classy and
i'm just curious i'm curious you know i
think one calls the heart we love
because
you always bring us joy and and touch
our hearts no pun intended in so many
ways
but showing that relationships are
complicated even
amongst best friends um erin what do you
think the the
teachable moment is here in seeing
a little bit of friction between these
these two women who have truly been
through everything together
i just think it makes it more relatable
if everything was perfect
on television it wouldn't it wouldn't be
all that interesting
number one but but it just wouldn't be
relatable i mean
i think it's really important for people
to see even
the healthiest relationships and
friendships have rough patches and
it's good to be able to see how those
people overcome those rough patches and
and find their way
back to each other so i hope that people
learn from it
now pascal i know that you and aaron are
very close on screen but also off-screen
so i'm curious when you're in those
scenes you're there together filming
and you have to be a little tough with
each other what were those moments like
on set
i think it started with a real
excitement
both of us were really excited to kind
of sink our teeth into it
and as we've seen that this tension kind
of
goes on for a few episodes so
after a few scenes of it i think both of
us
were thinking this this isn't that much
fun
we're not really no it was awful
like that not that much fun it was
brutal i hated it
it was very hard to commit to uh
it's just very challenging to be at odds
with pascal
i'll say that oh i don't know about that
welcome back kevin
aaron and pascal can i ask you from an
acting perspective
in order to get in the mindset of our
characters are upset with each other
are you staying apart on set that day or
are you two
able to you know hang out have a laugh
you know you know have a snack together
and then yeah bam go back in the scene
and and
you're not exactly best friends in that
moment
no we weren't keeping our distance i
think
uh in fact there was probably more of of
the usual
me not being able to stay in character
and like getting the giggles in a scene
with pascal
um and i think i also think it was
something that we discussed
a fair amount like wanting to make sure
that we told the arc of that story
in a way that felt authentic so i would
turn to pascal and say
do you feel like the way i'm delivering
this line makes sense like
does that feel authentic to you and
she's obviously i i trust her
opinion and i value her opinion and she
was able to say
no in fact you can do better
keeping it real always never saying
quite that not that it would be
out of character i just don't no
never in those words but always helpful
feedback i mean
we were there to support each other what
was confusing
is that and i think the fans are well
aware of this by now
but we block shoot and so it wasn't
it wasn't sequential like we didn't
film that first scene where we walk away
from the row houses
and and we didn't and then followed by
the next scene followed by
rosemary coming to visit her at the row
house and then she kind of snaps at
rosemary
like we didn't and so that was the
trickier thing that
yeah i said it snaps
um okay i'm just gonna say it wasn't
without cause i seem to recall rosemary
saying something about
jack's death not being important to
nathan so
we could just we could just go through
this again if you want
see this let's show it
for a second okay sure what i will say
is as we were filming it that's we were
often checking in about where
is this in the arc of this of this
like kind of fight or tension or
whatever where are we at with it because
it was it's hard to keep track of it all
the time and
and knowing and keeping it so it's
always progressing always moving forward
well i have to tell you it hits me like
a knife in my heart every time i have to
watch one of these uncomfortable scenes
and i hope
after what has it been i think three
episodes of of tension between rosemary
and elizabeth i'm ready for the finale
to have a big hug
and a little bit of resolution so i'm
going to keep my fingers crossed for a
happy ending
um kevin i want to go back to you and i
want to revisit a conversation that
we had around this time last year it was
the end of season seven
and you know we were talking about the
possibility of rosemary and lee
expanding their family and we've seen
little uh nuggets or or glimpses
into that could be a possibility
especially i loved how beautiful their
relationship with with rachel
was this season but i think fans are
curious going into the finale
um can you share any details about
the family planning front
well that's a complicated question isn't
it
the truth of it is is that of course um
this is something that we've been
working towards for a long time
but uh it's never a question of just
pulling the trigger on something and it
happens there's a lot of things that go
into that decision
there's a lot of dynamics that are
involved which decision do we make
which way do we go if if it's we choose
a
or b how does that affect everybody else
on the show how does that affect us
moving forward so it's a complicated
thing but i will say this we
are both completely on board for
wanting to expand the family in one way
or another so
i think that it's just been a long
ongoing question and i'm hoping that
uh if we get a chance to go again we'll
have
some more solid answers for you on that
one
i really want that i think that's a
logical and good destination for these
two it's just a matter of
how we get there okay so just a few
logistics to work out for
exactly just a few logistics to work out
pascal are you on team adoption or team
rosemary's pregnant
woo oh gosh
i am firmly one of those teams
yeah good answer good but i don't
actually i don't want to say which team
i'm on because
i still want it to reveal like a bit of
a surprise
and so if it even happens right like
um so i don't really want to say which
team i'm on
i definitely have an idea of what way i
think would be best for the show and for
the characters
but um but i'm not i'm reserving
i'm what is it pleading the fifth i'm
not sure
i'm not gonna say anything on that yes
okay kevin you'll have an opportunity as
soon as it's
as it's available yeah well i always
have an opinion but on this one my
opinion is that uh i love
how pascal got out of that and i'm going
to follow right behind her and see
myself okay then i'm going to look at
your
executive producer erin cracow oh
me too i know you're involved in the
storytelling of this series
and i would love to know your thoughts
on leigh and rosemary possibly someday
um welcoming a child or adopting a child
well i think lee and rosemary would make
the most excellent fun
loving parents and
i at the end of the day always want what
pascal
and kevin want for their characters so
they have my support and i think it
would be a very exciting
and fun story to tell i mean i will just
warn them
as i'm sure they know yes it isn't
always smooth sailing
working with babies i mean they've had
their fair share
yes of course i've done so many scenes
with baby jack but
you know i feel like i'm the one person
that actually
i don't mind i i don't i definitely
don't mind it i actually really enjoy it
even when it's not going smoothly i
love it because i just love how
unpredictable it is and you just never
know what you're gonna get
kevin i think a little less so a lot
less so
a lot less so but i love it even even
when things are
on
it's just a big jolt of
unpredictableness which
just excites me okay yeah
i i i don't mind jolt of excitedness but
i'm
also not sure i 100 percent by that you
love it
i've been beside you sometimes when it's
happening and loving it isn't the
expression that i see on your face
but it sounds great for tv so let's go
with that let's go with that
well and also are there any amazing cute
tender moments with baby jack in the
finale that fans can look forward to
you know sadly because of kovid not to
focus on our pandemic too much but
because of kobud we haven't really had
as much time with little jack and
with the the school kids on set and i
really feel like it's something that
we've been missing in season eight so
hopefully we get a season nine and can
can kind of you know reincorporate those
characters a bit more once the world
starts to open up and feel safer but
i'm trying to think of like particularly
sweet moments with the with the baby
i don't remember we shot it so long ago
i'm sure there's something sweet
it's the finale so i'm sure there's
something in there for everybody to grab
onto and
aaron your lips to god's ears we we need
a season nine we can't just
end season eight and i couldn't even
imagine
saying goodbye to these characters who
who are so near and dear to our hearts
especially
we know in the finale that elizabeth is
gonna make a big decision and start a
new
chapter in her life but how do you mean
yeah what's going on with that
where should i start how much time do
you have
you know going off of we just watched um
episode 11
and i have to tell you i feel like
elizabeth is more torn than ever i felt
like maybe at this point in the season
i'd have like a clear gut instinct or or
intuition about who she was leaning
towards
and i really feel like it's a 50 50 game
at this point
can you share a little insight into
where elizabeth's
mind is at going into this final episode
oh my um well
you've all seen the promos and you've
seen all of the episodes
up until the season finale so you know
she hasn't removed her wedding ring yet
um but it's coming spoiler alert so i
think that that's an indicator of
of where she is and just how long it's
taken her to
to really make peace with
moving on yes she's allowed herself to
have these
fun flirtations with these guys but i
think it's taken her this long
to work through the the grief the
anxiety
the you know nathan
lucas whatever it's it's all been
weighing on her and it's taken her this
long
um so i'm really
i'm grateful that i've had the
opportunity to play this
messy story um and to get to show a
different
few sides of elizabeth this season as
she navigates her way toward that
um that decision
was that i don't even know if that
answered your question but
that's what i'm going with no it did
because you know i i think
you first of all you can only reveal so
much we don't want any spoilers we want
to watch and be surprised
um but but yeah i think you guys have
done such an incredible job
of really giving us the ride of the
season you know we we
think one thing in episode four and then
we think something else in episode six
and then here we are at episode 11. you
know what i mean it's just it's been
this incredible journey um pascal i want
to ask you because obviously playing
um elizabeth's closest confidant and
she's been
um her pillar of support throughout this
entire journey i know it's hard i know
it's hard to pick and this is hopefully
the last time i'll ever have to ask you
this question
but if you have your best friend's best
interest
at heart who do you see her ending up
with oh gosh i can't believe we're gonna
have to answer
this again you saw the way that she
answered that last question she's gonna
slide through this no
no no no we already did one plead the
fifth no more pleading the fifth
i won't read the fifth i will give the
same answer that i
have always given which because
rosemary's always been unwavering she's
always been very clear about what team
she's on she's on team elizabeth
and she actually doesn't care team lucas
team nathan she honestly doesn't care
she's purely
team elizabeth and she only wants what's
best for elizabeth and she which
in her opinion is elizabeth just
opening her heart and to love
and that can be with either person i
really don't think
we've ever seen any indication from
rosemary that she has a preference
between these two
gentlemen like that they're both fine
they're both lovely she only wants
elizabeth to be happy
but didn't deidre ask what pascal thinks
oh is that a question i i technically
didn't i was focusing on what you know
what um
kevin look you're a great journalist
that's a great follow-up question
pascal as an objective fan and viewer of
the show
do you see someone who's got like a
little competitive edge
i don't see someone who has a
competitive edge
on the contrary i feel very similar to
your experience watching this season
where
i felt like as it was going along um
i thought one way and then i thought the
other way and then i thought
back to the original way and and then i
saw the teaser
for 11 and then now i so i jus i find
i've been finding myself flip-flopping
this season
watching of going who who is the right
person
where is elizabeth's heart like i
actually don't know
and um and that i think is intentional
for sure for sure um so yeah i just i
honestly don't know
i don't know i i will say i was team
lucas for a long time and then i watched
some episodes and i thought oh god no
of course she's supposed to be with
nathan and then
and then um and then i thought again
lucas because i saw that
that steamy little scene in his office
where
they she came out and she was all
flustered and like
cool me down and so then i thought whoa
okay
those fireworks we haven't seen with
nathan
certainly so i so you know i'm i'm
undecided back and forth
yeah back and forth okay kevin are you
kind of on the same 50 50 team or do you
have somewhat of a preference
i initially thought this was a show
about
a lady and a mountie and then i kind of
stuck with that in the beginning
and then all through last season i kind
of thought that that's eventually where
the show will land
and then this season i
paid more attention to what was going on
and i saw the relationships develop a
little bit more on screen that is
and one of the things that pascal and i
i think do well
is that we're good friends off camera
and when we're on camera we bring the
fun
with us and i think what started
happening a lot more with both
kevin and chris and aaron is they
started bringing some of their because
they're all quite good friends as well
and that
that chemistry is starting to come on
camera now and now
i have no idea but what i did do
is because on a completely selfish note
i want the show to go on for a long time
so i'm trying to get both guys to stick
around as long as they can so i want
them to buy
things they can't afford and they have
to stay on the show
like houses or boats or silly purchases
like that that they need to stay working
for
so that's my ambition now is to just
make sure both guys stay around
i don't care who ends up winning well
kevin i i think you're in luck because
aaron you've previously told us that
regardless of who elizabeth
ends up with both gentlemen are going to
be sticking around on the show that's
true correct
i i don't have complete and total
control over that you know
these guys are human beings who may make
decisions of course that
take them away from the show but as far
as i'm concerned like
i don't want nathan to go anywhere i
don't want lucas to go anywhere let's
let us keep these characters who we love
so much
i've heard way too much about the hope
valley black hole and how
characters disappear and let's keep
these people around who we love
so yes let's keep them 100
and and aaron just as we go into this
season eight finale i would love if you
could
indulge the hearties give us your best
teas and
and what do you think we're gonna feel
as we watch this final episode
oh i really could have
prepared something i guess um what are
you gonna feel
well i think there will be some very
real
tension emotional turmoil
satisfaction tenderness
um a lot of
heartfelt moments passionate moments
uh it isn't just one thing
in true when calls the heart fashion you
know this i've described this season as
feeling like kind of a
heartfelt rollercoaster and i think it's
gonna feel like that
that rush that you feel when you get off
a roller coaster where
it's just sort of overwhelming
everything that you've experienced and
i hope it is as satisfying for our
viewers as it was for us to film it
because i think we're all really proud
of
of what we've delivered this season ah i
cannot wait everybody please tune in
this sunday
hallmark channel 9 p.m when calls the
hearts
season 8 finale it's going to be
incredible
um pascal i want to ask you because you
know we've been tweeting every single
week we're begging please give us more
when calls the heart we want a season
nine
if we get if we're so lucky to get a
season nine is there anything that you
have in mind that you would love to see
explored more or tackled more
for my character or for the show and
anything anything you want
well i okay personally a personal wish
for me i always think rosemary really
thrives
in chaos she's one of those people that
i think just
handles chaos well or not well but she
just kind of gets a rush from it
and i like that i like seeing more of
that and i don't think we had that much
of
that element to rosemary's life this
season um
and so i'd like to see her kind of
trying to juggle
many many different things and
succeeding and failing
and all those things and then as far as
the show
um i really am looking forward to
um having the kids more involved in the
show
now that um you know i we're in kind of
a different
space pandemic wise and so i think
i think uh the kids bring a really fun
wonderful energy to the show
both the school children and also baby
jack and i
i'm excited to have that back as a part
of the show because i personally have
missed it
kevin well i work with the children a
lot
and so i
um i actually i mean i wear my heart on
my sleeve with this one i'd like to see
some resolution to the uh to their uh
uh potential resolution of
family matters i'd like to see where
this goes i'd like to
to finally see them
uh i love leigh and rosemary i i've come
to really love those characters over the
years
and elizabeth too of course but
i just think that
i would love to see them as a family
plain and simple i know it's hard
working with kids
i know pascal will lie about it but i'm
up for it
so i i think it'd be really fun i think
that we've been kind of going steering
the ship that way for a while
and uh i know that they've
we've started this whole kind of road to
um
self-fulfillment and finding things that
are meaningful
and i think that if you just
drop a kid right in the middle of all
that that would just
their their relationship would blossom
in a way that we just haven't seen yet
and i think that would be a lot of fun
to play as an actor
okay so family planning rosemary with a
little more chaos
aaron this next chapter hopefully that
we'll get to see of elizabeth
is there anything on your mind that you
would really love to get to do on this
show
well personally i i agree i'd really
like to bring
more of the kids back into the fold
because i think a large part of
elizabeth's identity is wrapped up in
being a teacher so
getting to have those scenes with them
again is really important to me
and then i think you know we have been
just well i'll say it we've been
dragging out this triangle for how many
years now
i think by the end of this season we'll
have a decision
if we get a season nine it would be
really nice to be able to
play out some of those like sweet
romantic scenes and kind of watch that
courtship blossom so um that's what i
would say for elizabeth
i would say for the show as a whole i'm
so
so happy that we were able to bring the
canfield family
into one calls the heart this season and
so i think if we can continue to learn
more about their characters and and
really see
how they fit into the life in hope
valley that can only
benefit our show they're incredible
actors and i think their characters are
really interesting as well
those are my feelings i couldn't agree
more i hope the powers that be
the producers i hope all of them are
watching and heard all those super solid
pitches
and fingers crossed for more magic from
one calls the heart again everybody
please tune in this sunday
hallmark channel 9 p.m the season 8
finale of when calls the heart
no one does a finale like one calls the
heart does a finale so i cannot wait to
see
what you guys deliver before i let you
go on a separate note everyone is so
excited
to see pascal and kevin take off the
rosemary and the lee hat
and we're going to see you jet off to
paradise in your new movie you had me at
aloha
so pascal you get a trip to hawaii i
mean
was this twisting your arm what was it
like going to paradise to film the whole
thing
the whole experience was just a pinch me
moment i just felt like every day
i turned to kevin at some point and said
is this really happening are we really
doing this
like it's happening we we made this this
is
our movie we developed it we created it
and
i just um it was it was really
a dream come true i don't know how else
to describe it it was a dream come true
kevin how did you feel being there in
hawaii living out all these
i saw some atvs waterfalls wow
it was every day was uh was fun i mean
working with this one is fun
period but we uh this was a long time
coming we
started this about two just over two
years ago and
the world went chaotic so things got
slowed down and
when we finally got there um we did this
thing
getting to hawaii was complicated and we
talked about this as we went
on our journey there i'm like well we
took that box we took that box we take
that box
and we just kept jumping through hoops
and then all of a sudden we were there
you know we got in late at night got to
the hotel and just kind of looked at
each other i'm like
here we are here we go it's happening
but we're actually here
and then each day just got better and
better it was just
fun from the moment we started in the
morning until we went back to the hotel
at night and uh
and in the end we've both seen a rough
cut and we're both extremely happy and
we think it was a lot of fun to do
when you come up with something like
this and it's your own baby and then
to see it finished and to be proud of it
is really
it's really something can you share just
for anybody who might not have you know
seen the
the clips that are online yet you should
go check them out because they're
hilarious and and the pictures are
breathtaking
can you just share a little bit about
what the movie's about and why you think
fans are gonna love it
sure well uh essentially
a little backstory so we were doing a
show one time
and an exec was there and she said what
do you guys want to do next
a friend of ours had just directed a
movie in fiji and we both got
jealous so we said we want to do a movie
in paradise
if we pitched an idea would you go for
it and they're like yeah sure so i
turned the pascal and i
said what do you want to be and she said
out of the blue i want to be
a travel blogger that's frustrated and
never been anywhere i'm like great i'll
be the opposite let's pitch that
so essentially that's what we have we
have a travel show
where um they've lost their host
pascal's character is the producer of
the show
and they need a new host so they bring
in my character who's kind of a wild fly
by the seat of his pants guy
she's a more by the book studious a type
and in the end the network decides to
make us because they see us bickering
and bantering behind the scenes and
decide to put us
in front of the camera together and so
we have very different ways about going
about the job
and it's chaotic and frustrating and
then eventually they find a way
to inspire one another and
you know find the good in the other and
take some of that on themselves
well my goodness i cannot wait to see
the two of you playing
battling tv hosts who actually do have a
really nice
relationship off screen as well and
pascal are you going to give us all the
feels i know
you know there's there's hurdles and
obstacles along the way but
are you going to hit us in the fields
yeah
yeah yeah the movie has everything um
but more than anything the overriding
the overriding mood is just so fun the
movie
is fun it clips along it's super fast
it's really funny it's sharp it's
it's it's a fun ride it's a really fun
ride
and that i'm so proud of that's i think
what kevin and i were hoping to
um give off like that's what we were
hoping to produce
and um that's what it is well
and there's definitely lots of feels too
yes
amazing you guys never let us down again
for a third time hardee's
i will be there tweeting hashtag
hardee's i'm sure aaron and pascal and
kevin will
too the season eight finale of when
calls the heart i can't believe it's
already here
sunday hallmark channel nine o'clock
thank you
fine fine fine humans for your time
today and congratulations on an
incredible season
thank you so much thank you tune in guys
hope you enjoyed the last episode
hopefully we'll see you next season